[Música]
vamos ahora a nuestra revista de prensa
de la mano de Marta Moya Marta Buen día
para usted Buenos días Ángela bien Vamos
a abrir con un artículo de análisis que
publicaste ahí en el que se desgranan
algunas de las causas que podrían estar
detrás de esta noticia de retoma de
relaciones entre Arabia Saudita e Irán y
que fueron anunciados apenas el pasado
viernes hablemos de eso así es Ángela
recordemos primero que las relaciones se
rompieron en 2016 después de que Arabia
Saudita ejecutará al clérigochita nirval
nim entonces Irán acusó Arabia de que
ese asesinato era por razones políticas
y religiosas y después Arabia acusó a
Irán de que había entrado armas en el
país y había bueno instalados a sus
células terroristas para causar
desórdenes y violencia Incluso en 2019
el príncipe heredero Mohamed Bill salman
de Arabia Saudita llamo y comparo al
máximo representante del gobierno iraní
él haya tolea men con Hitler ahora
después de cinco rondas de negociaciones
estas relaciones de diplomáticas parece
que se reabren con china como mediador y
este es un papel también importante que
va a jugar el gobierno chino entre estos
dos países para Irán reabrir la vía
diplomática es un paso importante
después de El aislamiento político
después de las protestas en el país tras
la muerte bajo custodia policial de Max
examen y que a finales de esta semana
cumplen seis meses además Busca también
que Arabia Saudita reduzca según este
artículo del minerlista ahí su apoyo al
Canal crítico con el régimen que eran
International y además también reduzca
su apoyo al grupo muy aidines por Irán
que es un grupo que el gobierno de
hebraim Rising considera terrorista
además Arabia También necesita que
renovar esas relaciones con Irán para
tener un el más protagónico en la guerra
de yemen Y es que según este análisis
nunca
ríad habría retomado estas relaciones
con Irán Sí y Irán no hubiese cedido un
poco de su influencia con el grupo de
los suties en la guerra de Irán no
obstante dice este análisis del Style
que aunque el acuerdo ha sido bien
recibido por varios países sería
prudente permanecer cauteloso porque
esta plagado de problemas estructurales
y profundamente arraigados en la región
pues es algo que apenas se anunció vamos
a cambiar de tema a Marta en Estados
Unidos poco a poco va creciendo el furor
por la carrera electoral yo le digo
preelectoral de Cara a las
presidenciales del 2024 uno de los
potenciales candidatos se republicanos
dijo muy polémico que la asistencia
Ucrania no debería estar entre las
prioridades cuéntenos Qué dice el New
York Times Pues sí Ángela y nos
referimos a rondesante y al gobernador
de California o sea de California de
Florida Perdón que se presentará como un
potencial candidato a estas elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 donde tendrá
probablemente que pugnar con el
expresidente Donald Trump estas
declaraciones fueron hechas en el
programa de Tucker clarson en el
programa estrella de El Prime Time de la
cadena Fox news el presentador
recientemente envió un cuestionario a
los potenciales candidatos republicanos
y claro las respuestas de The santis
indican un poco que puede Eso sí
presentarse como candidato que además
está peleado con Donald Así es todo un
espectáculo entre el seno del partido
republicano el presentador envía este
cuestionario ron de Santi responde Y
ayer clarson empieza a dar respuesta no
empieza a leer esas respuestas de The
santis y respecto a la política exterior
de santis dice que no debe ser una
prioridad para Estados Unidos seguir
apoyando militarmente a Ucrania de Santi
se separa así de Los Halcones
republicanos que critican constantemente
a vaiden por hacer poco con en ayuda
militar para Ucrania no es baladí que
estas declaraciones se dieran en el
programa de ataque al Carson porque él
es un fiel opositor a la participación
de Estados Unidos en Ucrania incluso ha
dicho que zelenski es el antihéroe y ha
criticado hasta su forma de vestir
diciendo que es el gerente de un club de
striptis estosis de Santi se alinea
control Perdón que también critica la
ayuda a kiev y también se alinea con el
40% de los votantes independientes
republicanos que dijeron según una
encuesta publicada en enero que
Washington está haciendo demasiado con
Ucrania pues está por verse en los meses
que quedan de Santi y se para fortalecer
una posible candidatura y bueno tener un
enfrentamiento potencial con Donald
Trump pero vamos ahora a cerrar en la
región en Colombia pese al anuncio del
gobierno de un nuevo proceso de paz con
las disidencias del extinto grupo
guerrillero de las FARC la propuesta no
parece que pudiera llevarse a término
con otros grupos como ya lo había
adelantado mandatario qué dicen las
editoriales de la prensa local sí Ángela
hemos destacado tres editoriales vamos a
empezar con el espectador que titula el
clan del Golfo traiciona el cese todo
esto viene a colación de un tuit que
publicó el presidente colombiano Gustavo
Petro el 31 de diciembre del año pasado
en el que anuncia en el que anunciaba un
cese bilateral de las hostilidades con
cinco grupos armados entre ellos el clan
del Golfo que es este grupo narco
paramilitar que no se ha sometido a los
diálogos de paz propuestos por el
presidente Petro no Y además últimamente
se habría infiltrado en un paro minero
causando desórdenes y violencias según
el editorial del espectador el grupo
narcotraficante de Lira sí considera que
va a ser reconocido como un actor
político y La Apuesta por la paz Total
no puede ser ingenua ni descuidar la
seguridad nacional destacamos también el
editorial del colombiano que titula la
paz total y el problema de identidad
crítica un poco ese cese al fuego
anunció el presidente Petro porque dijo
que nunca tuvo una firma bilateral nadie
ha visto las reglas cito textualmente de
verificación ni se designó a una
organización para tal tarea ni uno solo
de los requisitos mínimos para creer en
la existencia de un cese bilateral y que
este nuevo episodio del Clan del Golfo
en este paro minero pone y es una prueba
ácida para la paz total finalmente
destacamos una carta al director del
tiempo que dice que defender a la
población civil tiene que ser mandatario
para Gustavo Petro y que no hay
posibilidad de negociación con quien
abusa de la buena fe de la población
civil Un gobierno que se ha venido
complicando en los últimos meses y que
apenas comienza Marta Muchas gracias a
ustedes nos vemos mañana hasta mañana
Ángela gracias